All right, let's go next to where do we want
to go?
There's some interesting folks and there's
some dangerous folks to talk to.
Let's briefly speak to Justin from the United
Kingdom.
Justin from the U.K., you're on the air.
Hello.
Do you hear me?
I do hear you.
Hi, David.
Good to speak to you.
Likewise.
I was actually born in Chicago, in the United
States, but all my life in the U.K. so you've
only it seems like you've only taken on a
slight British accent.
Yeah, my dad's American.
And I listen to a lot of American folks, so
I got it.
You know, I think I've adopted some of the
times, as it were.
Perfect.
I was wondering when you guys are going to
sort out your shifts, you know what I mean?
Because, you know, I'm living here in the
U.K. I have the paradise of free health care
whenever I want to.
Right price.
And one day, you know, I'd like to move to
the US and make good use of that citizenship
that I have.
But from the outside looking in, it's a bit
like in some in some ways it's a bit of a
third world country.
Is it specifically the health care thing?
That's what's making you hesitate.
I guess it's not not just health care, it's
the health care, it's the complete lack of
paid vacation days.
Let's say I have a family in the future and
I have a kid.
I don't have to pay money to have a child
and have potentially higher infant mortality
rates that I would have here.
You need when you.
So let me see if you're saying lack of paternity
leave.
Not only potentially, but I'm speaking also
for the women of the world and any partner
I might have who would not be able to avail
themselves of that maternity leave and the
lack of paid vacation days is a serious matter.
Well, maybe maybe this is just a genuine misunderstanding.
But, you know, the truth is that in the United
States, things are very, very much tiered.
And there there are tiers of jobs where there's
plenty of paid vacation.
And insurance is is good enough.
I mean, the problem is that there's such inequality
that you have neighborhoods that are five
miles apart where the circumstances are dramatically
different.
I hate to say this, but if you were to come
to the United States with a good job waiting
for you, you get paid vacation, paid maternity
leave, a relatively modest health insurance
contributions.
I mean, what's horrible about the system is
that it does work quite well for people in
in certain jobs.
And it's an absolute embarrassing disaster
for people and others.
I hate to admit that, but depending on which
situation you were in, it could be a disaster
or it could be fine.
I mean, that's what's so horrible.
Yeah.
I mean, for me, it would definitely be the
case.
I'd be able to get a decent enough job to
have suitable health care, at least for me.
Right.
But it's still just something you have in
the back of your mind.
You know, as the economy takes a downturn
or whatever.
You don't have health insurance at that time.
Absolutely do.
And it's just, you know, as a matter of writing
out pros and cons of living in different countries
as we globalize, people tend to do have the
opportunity to move around and work in different
countries.
Right.
I know when you're looking at America compared
to, let's say, the Netherlands or other places
in Europe and you're taking the boxes, there's
just a lot of boxes left on the American side
to kind of make it look less appealing, which
I think is a same, no doubt about it.
I completely sympathize with you.
And yeah, I mean, we're in the U.K..
Are you?
I'm in Birmingham, Alabama.
Right.
I've never been.
But but certainly the UK has some fantastic
cities with high quality of life.
And I understand why why people might hesitate
to abandon that.
Delate.
OK, all right, we lost them, but very, very
well-made points, and I, I appreciate them.